تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام كيف يعقد
السوريون هدت
ومصالحات مع نظام لا امانه ولا عهد ولا
ذمه ولا كرامه
له كيف يتصالحون مع ثله من المجرمين
والقتله والسفاحين الذين اغتصبوا حرائر
سوريا ورفعوا شعار الاسد او نحرق البلد
وهجروا ملايين السوريين داخليا وخارجيا
واعتدوا على كرامات الناس وسطوا على
املاكهم كالغول
والتار الم يصبح لملايين السوريين ملايين
الثارات مع بشار الاسد وزبانيته يتساءل
ضيفنا متى يعلم السوريون ان من ينجز نصف
ثوره كمن يحفر قبره بيديه اليس حريا
بالسوريين ان يخزن السلاح حتى لو باعوا
املاكهم يتسائل ناشط سوري هل يعلم الشعب
السوري ان اجهزه الامن السوريه باتت اشرس
واوحش من الماضي بعشرات المرات وهي
ستصالحون كي تنتقم لاحقا شر انتقام من
السوريين جميعا يضيف اخر الم تمطر عصابات
الاسد سكان حمص بالقذائف بعد ان خرجوا من
المدينه القديمه بموجب هدنه مع النظام
اليس من يتصالح مع الاسد كالحمل الذي
يتصالح مع الذئب لكن في المقابل الا تسير
الهدنه والمصالحات على قدم وساق في بعض
المناطق وبرضا سكانها اليس من الاجحاف
توصيف الهدنه بانها عمليه ابتزاز رخيصه
نتيجه التجويع والحصار المنظم من قال ان
الاسد سيتعامل مع السوريين اذا صالحوه
كسبايا وغنائم كما كان يفعل التاتار في
الحروب القديمه الم يتصالح الجزائريون مع
الجنرالات رغم ذبحهم لمئات الالوف من
الشعب الجزائري في التسعينات اليس من يرفع
شعار لا تصالح يريد لسفك الدماء ان يستمر
من
قال ان جميل حسن ووفيق ناصر وعلي مملوك
وشبلي جنود ولص السيارات جامل البلعاس ابو
صخر ولص البيوت ابو خضر سيبقون للتنكيل
بالسوريين بطريقه افضع لو نجحت الهد الا
يرفع الرئيس السوري شعار المصالحه الوطنيه
في كل خطاباته اسئله اطرحها على الهواء
مباشره على لؤي
المقداد مدير مركز مسارات وعضو الائتلاف
الوطني السوري وعلى السيد شريف شحادي
الباحث والاعلامي السوري نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تؤيد الهد والمصالحات
التي يعقدها نظام الاسد مع المناطق
الثائره في سوريا صوت على هذا الموضوع
حوالي 9400 شخص
21%
نعم
79% لا شريف شحدي لو بدات معك بهذه
النتيجه طبعا هناك يعني نسبه لباس بها مع
المصالحه 21% مقارنه 79
لا السؤال الذي يساله السوريون
الان كيف نتوقع من نظام فعل ما فعله
بسوريا على صعيد تشريد 8 ملايين سوري
وتدمير منازلهم حتى لو مش هو ما دمرهم هو
مسؤول عن تشريدهم لانه لم يستطع
حمايتهم تهجير 5 ملايين سوري خارج البلاد
ماشي مئات الالاف من القتلى تدمير البيوت
تدمير البنيه التحتيه كل ذلك كيف تتوقع
كيف تقنع السوريين الانسان العادي السوري
الذي اغتصبت المخابرات اخته وزوجته وعملت
وسوت وسطت على املاكه وحرقت وسرقت
وسوت كيف بدك تقنع انه هؤلاء تصالحهم وتدن
طيب اولا انا اريد ان اعود الى مشهد قريب
ليس ببعيد في حمص انت تتحدث ان النظام قتل
ودمر وهجر انا وجدت العكس بالصوره على كل
المحطات من ادنى محطه الى اعلى محطه وجدت
ان الحكومه السوريه عندما خرج المسلحون من
حمص بدات فورا باعاده الاعمار وبدات فورا
بترميم ما حصل من ضرب وقتل
وبالكاد وجدنا ان هناك من يريد لهذه
الهدنه انلا تستمر او لهذه المصالحه انا
وجدت ان الحكومه السوريه قدمت من اجل ان
ترفع الهم عن عن المواطن لا ارى ان
الحكومه قامت بتهجير المواطنين انا وجدت
ان الاف مئات الالاف من المواطنين بداوا
يعودون لو كانت الحكومه هي التي شردتهم
كما تقول او يقول ضيفك او يقول غيره كيف
يعود هؤلاء على مراه ومسمع الحكومه
السوريه وجيش السوري كيف يعودون هؤلاء الى
بيوتهم كيف تكون المحافظه محافظه حمص
بتقديم الخدمات كهرباء وماء واذا اردت ان
تسال اسال كل المناطق التي عادت اليها عاد
اليها المواطنون بالمصالحه المصالحه هي
الهدف الاسمى للحكومه السوريه جميل جدا بس
خليني خليني اسالك طيب اذا كانت مصالحه
لماذا اطلق جيش ما يسمى بحماه الديار
عشرات لا بل مئات القذائف على ال السوريين
الذين خرجوا بموجب الهدنه الى شمال الى
الريف الشمالي كم قتلوا منهم بالامس
الاخبار كلها هذا النظام لا عهد له لا ذمه
له طيب ه هذه المجموعات خرجت بموجب معاهده
لماذا تقصف الداره الكبيره او الدار
الكبيره اولا اولا خرجوا هؤلاء باتفاق
امام مر العالم با ابدا اتحدى من يقول
قامت الحكومه السوريه واحد ا حتى ان من
خرج 1200 انا اقول لك 176 سوري والباقي
اجانب من الذين خرجوا من حمص حتى تعلم
ماذا يدور في حمص اثنين الحكومه السوريه
التزمت بما اتفق عليه احتراما لموقفها مع
كل من اتفقت معهم وبالتالي انا وجدت ان
هذه المصالحه قد ارهقت الكثيرين لانهم لا
يريدون لهذه المصالحه ان تتم يريدون النزف
الدم السوري يريدون تدمير ما تبقى من بنيه
تحتيه يريدون ضرب الجيش لذلك هذه المصالحه
تع الناس كلها تفرز الذي اتى من الخارج
لتدمير سوريا تفرز الذي تامر على سوريا
وتفرز المواطن السوري الذي يريد ان يعيش
بكنف الدوله واقول اكثر لك هناك من اراد
من المسلحين ان يصالح ويسوي وضعه تم
المصالحه وتسويه وضعه والان يعيش مع اهله
في امان وسلام ما يقال ما يقال عن ان
الحكومه السوريه تنكث عهودها انا اقول لك
حتى مع المجرمين الحكومه السوريه لم تنكس
عها واضح تماما بتحط زلمه عمره 80 سنه على
قائمه الارهاب اللي هو و على
ضحك انا بحكيلك عن شغلات شخصيه شغلات ما
بدي الناس انا بدي اتكلم انا اتكلم مشان
بتكلم عندما مملوك وبقيه
المجرمين انا اقول انا اقول هناك مصالحه
بدات في سوريا وطبقت في المناطق التي
ارتقيت فيها ان تكون مصالحه وسارت لماذا
يون لماذا يسطون على بيوت الناس لظه لماذا
يسرقون كل حمص هل شاهدت الجيش السوري وهو
يسرق كل بوت ح
القديمه اتحداك لا لاا اتحداك اذا كان
هناك عسكري واحد اقدم على مد
يده شفنا المسلحين نحن شفنا مسلحين ابدا
كان الجيش السوري ج ابدا من كان من كان من
كان داخل من كان داخل حمص القديمه هم
المسلحون واعترف الناس اصحاب البيوت هلا
من اصحاب البيوت واحد صاحب بيت بقول لك
سروا لي بيتي انت بتقول له لا الجيش سر لك
من كان من كان داخل حمص القديمه من كان
داخل حمص القديمه المسلحون
راحين لؤي مقداد الرجل يقول لك في اللحظه
التي خرج فيها المسلحون من حمص القديمه
بدات الدوله تعيد كل الخدمات بدات الدوله
باعاده الاعمار بدات تعيد الكهرباء ه هذه
المصالحات الكثيرون لا يريدونها لانهم
مستفيدون منها لانهم يريدون ارهاق سوريا
لانهم يريدون تدمير الجيش وكل ذلك من هذه
الامور اذهب الى الناس لو لم تكن هناك
مصالحات لماذا عاد الكثيرون الى حمص
انبسطت يا سيد لا الواقع بالضبط تفضل
الواقع
تفضل تفضل مساء الخير يعني دكتور فيصل
طبعا يعني بالتاكيد ما ورد بكلام ضيفك
يعني للاسف في كلام وارد يعني ما بقدر
اجاوب عليه يعني عندما يقول لك خرج من حمص
1300 42 منهم سوريين 176 176 سوريين
والباقي من وين سال الافغان حمص صار له
سنتين تحت حصارك طب طول بالك ط انا ما
اعطتك حمص سنتين حمص سنتين تحت حصارك هذول
الكائنات الفضائيه اللي اجوا عليها كيف
فاتوا يا استاذ شريف لكن بكل الاحوال وانا
قبل دخولي باي محور دكتور فيصل وباعتبار
المحور هو مصالحه وعم تسالني عن المصالحه
انا كيف اليه المصالحه وكيف تعرفون
المصالحه انا اعرف ان المصالحه هي بين
شخصين ا هو يعتبر ما حصل بحمص مصالحه طب
في طرفين تصالحوا ما نتصالح مع من في طرف
هجر وطرف احتلال فات كيف
تصالحوا الجيش ليس الجيش العربي السوري
ليس نحن هلا متفقين انه نحن متفقين ماقاطع
بقين انه كل واحد يوصف بالطريقه اللي
بتريح بتقوللي جيش بيضل تضل خ راتك خان
مضطر ارجع بتاريخ المصالحه مضطر ارجع
بتاريخ المصالحه الى البدايات لانه مسلسل
بشار الاسد ونظامه مع مصالحه ومسلسل طويل
ابتدا عصره الحديث ب 11/3 201011 وعندما
كان في بضعه اطفال بدرعا مزعوج زعلانين
فاتى بهم عاطف نجيب ابن خاله بشار الاسد
ليصالح وهيك طلع اول واحد منهم بلا مصالحه
وبدك تحملني جايب لك معي صور عامل لك
اياها مسلسل مسلسل
تصويري ف خرجوا من المصالحه في البدايه
عندما اتى بهم ثم اتى بامهاتهم عندما خرج
اهالي درع وانتفضوا وبدات المصالحه باول
طلقه في درعا عندما استشهد اول شهيد في
درعا ب 18/3 20111 عندما خرجت بقيه المدن
لنص اهاليهم ل نصت الشعب السوري كيف كانت
المصالحه بتعرف كيف تتذكرها هي الصوره
بالبيضاء هي الصوره التي قلتم عنها تورا
بورا وجابوها منش من البشم مثل هي الصوره
هي الصوره م جيشه الامن
السياسي بس سؤال يا ابن
جبهم هذا هذا مو العسكري تبعك
ونزلت الدبابات الى الشوارع وهي اطفال
سوريا قدام دباباتكم هيك كنتم عم تصالحو
لا مش ما بيهمك لانه باخر نهار عم تنام
انت ولادك وانت اين تنام يا اخي انا هول
هول حامل هم تحم هم انت تحمل هم نفسك بم
بسويسرا انا بنام بسويسرا انا بنام
بسويسرا بس وقت شوف هدول ما بقول يعني
عرفت كيف بحترمهم شوي ثلاث اطفال قدام
دبابه شويه اخلاق بكل الاحوال وابت مسلسل
التهجير هؤلاء التهجير هؤلا المخيمات
بتعرفهم وين بالاردن بالزعتري بهج سليمان
سفير هك شفتوا شي مره نزل على الزعتري
اطمن على 800 تنزل انت عم
تقب يا عيني
ص بدك تحكي كيفك لا بد تحكي بوئق
وادله
شضل حكيت كل خليه يحكي كلامه نزل بهج
سليمان الى هذا المخيم سفيرك شفته بهذا
المخيم مو سفير الشعب السوري ولا سفير
بشار الاسد ق سفي نزل شاف الشعب السوري لا
مه فاضي عم يشبح عم يتجسس يا سي هذه
المخيمات من افتعلها ينزل اليها ومن يقبض
عنها
اخي اذا بتد هذا الحكي من
يلا دقيقه دقيقه خليني نوقف البرنامج شوي
خليني نوقف البرنامج طلعوا سياحه على الار
كمل كمل عم يستجم شو بك يا زل محترم الناس
شوي شو صاير لك انت احترموا الناس
معسكرات
كان اخي انا فتحت المعسكرات كانت ضلت
فاضيه لو ما شرد لا لا مو نحن شردنا من
شردهم من اتى ويحمل السلاح ضد الحكومه
السوريه مشان الله
اقول دقيقه لؤي لي لي دقيقه شو هلام لي
خليني انا ارجع للنقاش ما بدنا يضيع
النقاش كير سيد هو سال سؤال انه هناك 800
ال سي انت عاوزين تصالحوا 800 ال سوري في
الزعتري وفي المخيمات انت عضو مجلس شعب
مسؤول عن الشعب السوري
استطل ليش اولا اولا قصه المخيمات قبل
الاحداث ما تدور في سوريا كانت مفتعله
وجهزت
تركيا قالت
الحكه قالت الحكومه السوريه من يرغب
بالعوده الى سوريا فليتفضل مشكورا مسموح
له ان يعود الى داره يعني وم يريد ان يسوي
وضعه فليتفضل يدخل الى سوريا لكن اللي عم
يقبض بالاردن وتركيا على ثمن الواحد 2000
دولار يا زلمه يا زلمه هلا انت بتروح
سياحه سوري على الاردن سياحه سياحه هول
بالاردن طول
بالك خل بس خل اذا بتروح سياحه على الاردن
او رايح تدرس ما بخليك تفوت الامن الاردني
ليسجل لك فيشي انك انت لاج مشان اقبض عليك
اذا ما بتعرف
اعرف
عم يقبلا ليش عم يقعد اخي في واحد عم يقبض
عليه هو ليش عم يقعد في مجال هجر مين هجره
اسال ليش ما رجع لعندك لش لانه في مناطق
فيها مسلحين الى يعني بس هذا السبب بسال
يعني سبب انه انت يا دوله يا مح امبارح
بحمص امبارح بحمص عندما خرج المسلحون عاد
الناس مباشره كل اهل حمصه ناس عادوا
خلص خلص بقى استاذ سر ب بجاوبك ها جاوبك
بعد اولا
اوص عندما فتحت لا تروح على الطائفيه لن
تنجحوا فيها ابدا لن تنجحوا فيها اسمعني ه
اسمعني هك اسمعن امبارح عندما دخلوا الناس
فتحت الحكومه السوريه الطريق لمن يريد ان
يدخل دخل
مسيحي باعترافك ما طلع تصريح من وزير
اعلامك عمران الزعبي قال في خرج من حمص
1400 مصلح و000 مدني مين ال 2000 مدني ليش
طلعوا ال 2000 مدني من احيائهم من وين
هدول في ناس في ناس انتقلت في ناس كانت
محتجزه جوا وانتقلت الى
ما اذا من خرج من حمص هم المسل بس دقيقه
لانه انا بدي احكي طائفي لا بدي اورجيه لا
بدي اورج بدي صك يا اخي شو بك صور ما بدك
هذا ضريح خالد بن الوليد بحمص من دمره مين
انا لا اسالني مال من خرج على شاشه
التلفزه وقال نحن ريك تعليقاتك و تصريحاتك
الرسميه انت وجمهورك تب بدنا نطلع خ
بتحداك بتحداك تحدي شري
خالد هذا الكلام هذا الكلام غير
دقيق خالد بن الوليد من قام بضرب الجامع
هي المجموعات
مقف رح اوقفو اسمه ليك بصراحه لا فهمنا شي
وراح الكلام كله على الفاضي طكي طائفي بس
ما بديكي طائفي هدول بينزلوا على ضريح
خالد بن الوليد هذا السيد المعمم وهذه
الميليشيات حامله علم ابو الفضل العباس
نزلت على ضريح شو نازل ضريح خالد اخي خذ
على كربلاء شو عرفك الصوره هك لا وين
الص البيض جايبلك منه صغير مشان خليها
فيها صغير بك تاخذ حده غيره يرور بش بش
عنص بش عندي صور
غير ما بدنا نخرج على الموضوع نرجع لموضوع
الهد نعم ما العيب في هذه الهد نت اذا
كانت تعود بالاستقرار الى سوريا وتضع حدا
لسفك الدماء بغض النظر بغض النظر كيف ترد
مش هذا هو السؤال جاوبني يا سيدي يا سي يا
سيدي ليس هناك من هدنا بشار الاسد افتعل
مسرحيه في بضعه مناطق لياتي بصندوق انتخاب
يحطه يقول للعالم انا عملت انتخابات
الهدنه او المصالحه يجب ان تصالح شعب هل
ستصالحون مليون جريح ومليون معاق من حرب
بشار الاسد هل
ستصالحون مصالحه فعليا تاريخيه ان يسامح
مليون ام واب بدماء ابنائهم ان يسامح
ضحايا اطفال الغوطه بمجزره الكيماوي مثلها
معارضه ان يصالح من قصفته بالبراميل حلب
اللي دمرتها اذا بصالحه يا سيدي ستكون
تاريخيه يا استاذ استاذ شريف ليش انا تفضل
تفضل تفضل تفضل يا سيدي من يريد ان يصالح
من هل يصالح الضحيه يصالح القاتل يعني قل
لي بعدين بشار الاسد شلون بده يصالحهم قل
لي برجع لهم اولادهم بعيشوا يعيش لهم
اياهم يلا ابعثنا عين يا استاذ شريف بعث
لي
500000 شهيد من تحت الانقاض هم في حضن
الوطن تحت التراب مو القتله تبعتك فك عن
جد هذا حضن الوطن حضن الوطن ليس ليس ليس
حزاء بشار الاسد حضن الوطن المدفونه تحت
الشه خلكم مث طيب البعض يقول انه النظام
لا يتحدث عن هدنه ولا عن مصالحه هو
يريد توبه هو يقول للسوريين ايها السوريون
توبوا يا سيدي طيب ماشي انا وفيق ناصر
رئيس المخابرات العسكريه يقول لي قريد
قريد باب التوب تسكر قال الكر هذا راس
الطرش قال باب تصور معنا قال يعني شو قال
بده توبنا يعني ص يا اخي عم اقول لك انا
الشخصيه انه لازم توبوا يا ابن 6 الف
صرماي انت بكب
الناس حسب يقول
السوريون يقول عن 6 ال هذا الكلام هذا
الكلام هذا الكلام لا ياتي في اطار
السياسه اولا في اطار السياسه اعطيني شوف
ودك تحكي كلام بدي يجيب عليه اثباتات اما
من الارض او من الصحف
لا مين قالك هيك
مين يا اخي لاجيب كلام من عندك الله يخل
يا اخي الرئيس الاسد قال
نحن يا اخي لا تحكي هذا الكلام اذا ما في
شيء مثبت قال نحن يجب علينا ان ندعم
المصالحات التي تجري في اي منطقه ونفتح
باب الحوار مع اي مواطن سوري وفي حمص وفي
السيده زينب وفي المعضم جرت هناك مصالحات
وعادت الناس الى بيوتها انا بقوللك ما بده
مصالحه الناس الذين استفادوا من تهجير
الناس الذين قتلوا الناس الذين دمروا الب
اخي امبارح اتيل كرتون اوير الكريتون
فجرته المجموعات الارهابيه بتصوير
كمانن فجرنا
حدا الجامع الاموي جامع الاموي فجروه في
حلب قطع الماء في حلب قطع الكهرباء في ح
خلي كملك يا اخي بس مشان ما نرجع لنفس
الاسطواني انا عم بسالك طيب كيف البعض
يقول نهاد اسماعيل يقول نظام الاسد معروف
بانه يفي بوعوده فقط لاسرائيل منذ 40 سنه
اما مع الشعب السوري طيب بدي اسالك
الاكراد انا سالت احد الاخوه المسؤولين
قلت لهم لماذا تصالحتم مع الاكراد مسؤول
سوري بعيد عن الاضواء تعلم ماذا قال قال
نحن لم نتصالح مع الاكراد نحن حيد هؤلاء
كي نتمكن وعندما نعود سندوس على الاكراد
واحدا واحدا هذا رجل امن سوري يقول هذا
اللامس يا اخي في مصدر رسمي على طول هو
الذي يتحدث وفي دوله وفي قانون كل واحد ما
قي كل كل واحد كل واحد ما ق لي كلمتين
اولا اولا اولا تعامل الحكومه السور شو ما
بدك احكي الحكومه السوريه تتعامل مع الشعب
وفق ما يرتئيه هذا الشعب من مصلحه له
والمصالحات انا اعلم ان هناك ثوره على هذه
المصالحات دليل انها نجحت ودليل انها
اصبحت مخرز في عين الاخرين الذين لا
يريدون وقف سفك الدم السوري ولا يريدون
للجيش العربي السوري
لؤي لؤي لؤي لؤي لؤي احكي لي عن المصالحات
يقول لك الرجل هناك مصالحات لؤي حضران
نديم قطيش وقت بقول لك رؤيا شريف شو بك يا
استاذ شريف شو صار صار شي بس انت عم تحكوا
شغلات بدنا معلومات احكي لي عن المصالحات
الم يحصل الم تحصل هناك مصالحه في المعظم
نعم جاوبني يا سيدي لم يحصل لم يحصل اي
مصالح لم يحصل اي مصالحه حتى الان مشكله
بشار الاسد ونظام البراميل عنده مشكله مع
خزان المعضم هناك خزان في المعضم هو عنده
هوايه البراميل يريد ان يرفع علمه على هذا
الخزان مهما كلف الامر تركهم سلاحهم لشباب
وفوت لكم اكل وحطوا لي هالعلم حطوا له
اياه يومين وشالوه صور الانجاز الاسطوري
بانه دخل الى الم لم يحدث مصالحه في يا
سيدي لا يحصل مصالحه مع انسان في سوريا في
انسان مع انسان واحد في سور لم يحصل واح
لم ي شو ما هي مقياس المصالحه يا استاذ
فيصل اعود واقول من قياس المصالحه ان تحل
ازمه الشعب ومشكلته في ازمه بين شعب وقاتل
كيف بس يا اخي منطقه منطقه باخر نهار
بتخلص سوريا كلياتها منطقه مصالح يعني كل
ما فوت العالم حليت مشكل طيب يلا يا شو ب
برزي برزي يا سيدي عندما تكون في جوار
افرع الامن ومحاصر من كل افرع الامن وتعيش
هذا الواقع هذه الصوره بس تعيشها شو بدك
تاكل ترفع له علم لبشار الاسد خمس دقائق
بس مفكر بهذا الكلام رح اكلمك عن مصالحه
دوما يا سيدي مصالحه دوما اجوا جابوا تجار
اجوا جابوا تجار التي لم تحصل خليني نكمل
اجوا جابوا تجار دوامي مقيمين بالشام بضع
تجار جابوهم افرع الامن عرض عليهم احد
اجهزه الامن وقال له يا شباب بدنا باي حال
من الاحوال نرفع العلم في الداخل واجابه
تجار انه عندكم معتقلين وفي معتقلين اثنين
علويه عمدا داخل دوما قالوا لهم طب ما
بدكم المعتقلين اجابهم بالحرف لا معتقلين
ولا غيره بدنا نحط العلم هذا اللي هامه
بشار الاسد بده يصور العلم انه حرر دوما
هذه هي المصالحه لكن دعني اقول يا سيدي
مصالح يا سيدي لكن مصالحه حمص وهذه
المصالحه العظيمه وهون بدي اذكر حادثه احد
اصدقائي بس فتوا على حمص والنصر العظيم
قالي ل كان لؤي من سنتين لما قالوا لنا
فاتوا على بابا عمر وحمص القديمه وبلشوا
يطبلوا ويزمر وحسن نصر الله المجرم تبعكم
بروح بنيه لبشار الاسد بيبعث له برقيه
عرفتي مثل واحد مرت زلمه ومرته حسن نصر
الله انا في رايي وراي العرب هو الامام
الحسين لهذه
ال انا هذا رايي انت رايك ح
حع
يا سيدي حسن نصر الله الحسين تبع وبشار
الاسد الرب تبع خلص نعتبره مثل ما بدك بكل
الاحوال طيب انا عم بحكي يعني انت على
اساس مداق عرفت والحسين شو بدك ف خليه على
جناب خليكم بي شو
بدك قاللي قال لي يا سيدي قاللي عندما
طبلوا وزمر لبابا عمر لكن شو كنتم محررين
هي اللي فتوا عليها حمص القديمه هي حمص
القديمه اللي فتوا عليها بعيده 1000 متر
1000 متر عن بابا عمر ولمن يصور انه تم
انسحاب يا سيدي عندما خرج ياسر عرفات من
لبنان طلعوه من لبنان على تونس شباب الجيش
السوري الحر والثوار طلعوا من حمص القديمه
الى الدار الكبيره وتلبيسه والرستن يعني
نعم بدهم يقاتله هك لا بده لا بدك تقتلهم
هك لانه الغدار الغدار بعدهم ما وصلوا
لهناك كان ضاربه ثلاث صواريخ فراغيه لا لا
اذا بتريد لا لا اذا بتريد بدك تخالف
وقائع الثاني بورجيك صور من البيسه اذا
بتريد ضربهم بالدار الكبيره وهدد باستخدام
السلاح الكيميائي لكن بقول لك اياه انه ما
طلعوا الشباب يعني شباب بعدهم ريف حمص
يعني هي عن جد شو عملت شو
عملت اسال يا لؤي انا لا بدي اسال مثل ما
سالته طيب سيدي البعض يسال لماذا يصور
النظام السوري عمليات تجويع نازيه وفاش و
عمليات حصار فاشيه وناز لبعض المناطق اه
وتركيع هذه المناطق اه لماذا يصور على
اساس هدت الهدنه تحصل والمصالحه تحصل طيب
الم يضطر اهل المعضم ومخيم اليرموك و
والغوطتين والى اكل الكلاب والى اكل
الاوراق الشجر بس دقيقه دقيقه طيب عندما
تفرض على هؤلاء ان ياكلوا لحم القطط
والكلاب اه وباخر النهار بتقول لي مصالحه
يا اخي انا بدي انا بدي اسال طول بالك انا
بدي اسالي طول بالك بدي اسال سؤال التالي
جاء مندوب من منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
وقدمت الحكومه السوريه مع الهلال الاحمر
اليني والهلال الاحمر السوري كل
الامكانيات وضعتها تحت تصرف منظمه التحرير
فتحها من اجل دخول المواد الغذائيه قالت
هي سل الغذائيه تفضلوا من اوقف السل
الغذائيه اسال الذي خرج في تصريح علني من
بيروت اول ي الشعب السوري عم
ينتحر هذا انتحر هذا
انتحر خليني نكمل خليني نكم قدمت خليني
نكم قدمت الحكومه السوريه كل التسهيلات
ومنعنا من ادخال الطعام والمساعدات
المجموعات مسلحه بس ز المعظم هلا حضر حكيت
عن المعضم الان نجحت المصالحه في المعضم
وادخل الجيش الطعام الى المواطنين شو دخل
كل شيء دقيقه د دخل كانت الشروط كل عائله
تحصل على علبه سردين وكيلو عدس
المميه كلامك مو صح الفر لا لا لا لا
كلامك مو صح ولدي الدليل قامت قامت وزيره
الش لا قامت وزيره شؤون الشماعيه علنا
علنا قامت وزيره شون الشماعيه والعمل
بتقديم المساعدات على مراه من الناس لكن
هناك من اراد تخريب المصالحه في المعضم
وبدا باطلاق النار ليلا على الجيش السوري
اخي انا لقول لك شغله المصالحه عندي ثلاث
نقاط المصالحه تؤدي الى حقن الدماء وتعود
بالنسيج الاجتماعي السوري هذا ممنوع
بالنسبه للمسلح طيب كيف بده اه تعود
النسيج السوري طيب انت دقيقه دقيقه 8
مليون
شخص يا اخي طيب بدي اسالك سؤال انت مش
مسؤول عنه بشار الاسد لم يقتل سوريا واحدا
ماشي لم يقتل سوريا واحدا وثان ملايين
هجرهم الارهابيين وخ مليون طلعوا لاجئين
الارهابيين والارهابيين دمروا سوريا طيب
اليس من حق السوريين ان يقولوا لهذا
الرئيس
حلعن يعني بعد مامينا طيب حل لحظه لحظه في
كل دول العالم الان يجري مشاكل في
اوكرانيا لا تستطيع الدوله في كل المناطق
ضبط الامور هذا امر طبيعي لحظه لحظه شوي
لحظه شوي في فرنسا
حصل لا لا يا اخي حاجه تضخمي ارقام
معناتها نن مرحبا امم المتحده يا اخي
مرحبا امم متحده لك دافنينه سوا تبع الامم
المتحده يا دكتور الان الان المصالحه
الوطنيه التي تجري في سوريا ليس للخارج
مصحه انا رح اقوللك الدليل انا معي اسم
شخص كان من المجموعات المسلحه واعتقل قال
لنا بالحرف التالي قال كلما اتت موضوع
المصالحه ازداد الدفع المالي
السعودي حضر المال السعودي من اجل ان لا
يقف يقف الدم من اجل ان لا يقف الدم هذا
ما تحدث به احد الذين كانوا يقاتلون بس
خليني
كم الحكه السور دقيقه بس دقيقه بس بدي
اسالك هؤلاء الذين دمروا سوريا وهجروا كذا
مش ارهابيين ولاد 60 ارهابيين ارهابيين
ولا لا طبعا لماذا تجري هدنا ومصالحات مع
الارهابيين ليش
ع قلت لنا قبل انه ليس لديك مشكله مع
الشعب السوري مشكلتك مع الارهاب طيب الان
لماذا لماذا تعمل هدت مع المعظم ومع ريف
دمشق ومع حمص ومع درعه ومع كذا كل الشعب
السوري ارهابي بس خليني خليني اجاوب اولا
الحكومه يجب ان تكون هي الاب الكبير لكل
مواطن سوري حتى ولو حمل حتى لو حرقت
بيوتهم وسرقت سياراتهم
اه حتى لو اللص هذا لص السيارات ابو صخر ك
لم يتركوا بيت في المنطقه الجنوبيه الا
وسرق
مي كيف تعقد هوتت مع نصوص مع قتله مع
مجرمين لحظه الدوله على كل شي طول بالك
الدوله ليست تقاضي الناس ايضا تصلح الناس
اذا كان
هناكي شو دخلني بام صخر بام صخر اذا كان
هناك اذا كان هناك منم
الناس اذا كان هناك من حم السلاح الدوله
يجب اصلاحه اذا اراد الاصلاح وهذه اليه
فيها سوريا لكن انا قل لي من يريد ان يعكر
صف المصالحات القادمين من الخارج الذين لا
يتمنون لهذه المصالحات ان تتم اذا تمت
المصالحه اما سوف يقتلون او يعودون جميل
جدا دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه لؤي مقداد ليس لكم
مصلحه في المصالحات يا لؤي طلع فيه ليس
لديكم مصلحه في المصالحات لانها تضر
بالبزنس بتاعكم كمعارض بكل هذا الكلام صح
ولا لا يقوللك الرجل ارهابيين الدوله
كبيره قال تصور الدوله اللي بتدير بدير
وحده مفعوصه بتعرف تدير الدوره الشهريه
تبعها بديره لبشار الاسد بعرف
مللي
اس عندما رئس دوله عندما رئيس دوله دقيقه
راس الدوله يجب ان يستوعب الجميع مش وحده
فصعون بتروح بتقوله
احز لظه لظه عندما نتكلم نحن عندما نتكلم
عن امور السياسه وامور البلد يجب ان
تحص يجب هذا اللام
م اولا اولا لنبدا اولا نبدا بشهاده
الدكتور الاستاذ
عندما يحقق مع احدق
لاط عندما كان يحقق مع احد المعتقلين وقال
له اننا نريد ان نصالح عرفت لكن يمنعونا
بعض المعارضين ومثل ما عم تقول نحن اساس
المصالحات نحن عم نمنعها يا سيدي يا سيدي
لم تحصل في سوريا ولن تحصل في سوريا حتى
اللحظه حتى اللحظه اي مصالحه حقيقيه
اعترفت بعضمه لسانك تصور لين وصلته يعني
عندما قالوا الامريكيين الدواء مقابل
النفط او النفط مقابل الغذاء كنا نقول هذا
مفهوم غير انساني اعترفت بعضمه لسانك
عندما ركع اهالي المعظمين ورفعوا العلم
عرفت ادخل لهم لا لا هيك ما بمي
الحال قال لي ادخل الجيش العربي السوري
المساعدات الى المعظمين صح اذا من كان
يقطع المساعدات والغذاء والجيش العربي الس
حرره المعضم قام الجيش بادخال حر
النا حر من الملحين تركت سلاح كل الشباب
المعضم لم يسحب اي قطعه سلاح وهذا الحكي
كذب عرفت ادخل الجيش العربي السوري
المساعدات الى المعظم عندما رفع علم بشار
الاسد سوريا عالم بشار الاسد بشار
الاسل عندما ادخل المساعدات ادخل لهم
الطعام بعد ان قتلهم من الجوع بالنسبه
لموضوع من ي ال وان تضايقت لانه قاللك ان
لونا بتدير
الد
عمي شهرزاد الجعفري شهرزاد الجعفري ابنه
سفير بشار الاسد في امريك تبع تعليمات
الصباح قول هيك احكي هيك هذا كلام انا
براي انا براي انت ضعين تبحثون عن انتم
ضايعين تبحثون
عن شاء الله ه ماهر الحجار
مشنا ليش
تح سور شريم
شري شري سؤال اذا نحنا اهالي الشهده
والمعتقلين عنده ارب شهاده اخواته نح ما
فينا نقبل نصالح معقول حدا يقبل يصالح بس
اساله لشريف شح لما يرجع ينام على
المخده انت سؤال انت سؤال انت سؤال خليك
عم تقت له اللي ما بده يصالح خليك بس سؤال
يا اخ يا اخي بس سؤال انت بتعرف انا عندي
سؤال انت اليوم بتنام انت مرتاح سؤال هذا
النظام الذي يقوده الايراني نظام الملالي
وحزب الله هلا بتقول لي لا اللي عم يحرر
جيشك الجيش العربي السوري تبعك هو اللي عم
يحرر طيب فيك الصبح تسحب حزب الله طيب انا
ممكن كلامه كلامه صح اذا اذا ما
فندته بحب بعدين بدي اسال سؤال يا اخي انا
الله انا عندي اسئله اليوم انت عضو مجلس
هدول اللي بتقولوا فيه تبع قيل عليك قياده
المجرات ولازم تقود الكوكب
وبتزف كب ما حدا حك حدا بتخليني احكي ولا
لا بتخليني احكي ولا لا عملتوا دستور
رحتوا فصلته مشان نتصالح وعدلته الماده
الثامنه فصلت له اياه وطوله وع سنين و شو
كذا ف ليش ليش 10 سنين بدي اسال ليش يجب
ان يكون 10 سنين مقيم بشكل دائم في
الجمهور
باا هيك يعني انت تعتبر الشرعيه
ان انت تعتبر الشرعيه
جابني جابني على سؤالي الشرعيه ان يكون
مقيم لا ما عم تجاوبني 10 سنين بشكل
متواصل هون ت الشريه هؤ لازم
يكون في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه 14
عام رئيس الجمهوريه يجب ان يقوم من يريد
ان يرشح نفسه لرس الجمهوريه دقيقه اذا
بشار الاسد لما جابوه من من بريطانيا
وسلموه رئيس لم يكن رئيسا شرعيا في معاق
حاكمنا 14 سنه رئيس شرعي
اخ
س لظه كان يعمل دوره في امريكا لم يك
مقيما لحظه شوي وكان الدستور يسمح لكل
مواطن يعني كان دستور يعني كان دستورنا
تركيب على بش بشار الاسد اليوم غير شرعي
بدستور غير مرته البريطانيه مطان لا مو
بريطانيه اعطيني وثيقه اعطيني وثيقه فواز
الاخرس انا بعرفه لا لا مو بريطان لا مو
بريطان خلص يا اخي خلص يا اخي اخي
حلون هي
حلون خلص يا
عمي خلع البعض يقول بعض النشطاء وصلتني
رسائل كثيره يقول ايها
السوريون اذا
كنتم تامن على انفسكم من اجهزه المخابرات
السوريه التي تستشر وتستوحي وتقول ان
المخابرات في المستقبل ايها السوريون
ستكون اشرس واوحش بمئات المرات ايها
السوريون من كان لديه بقره حمار يبيع
ويشتري سلاحا لمواجهه المخابرات لمواجهه
المخابرات مش انا يا اخي مش انا ليك
يقولوا بس دقيقه يقول لك من يح من ينجز
نصف ثوره كمن يحفر قبره بيديه ايها
السوريون سيتعامل معكم بشار الاسد
ومخابراته كسبايا
وغنائم كنا سبايا هؤلاء عم يتعامل مو صح
هلا الذي ضرب الذي ضرب بالكيماوي دقيقه
الذي ضرب بالكيماوي والذي دمر مدن باكملها
شو ممكن يسوي بالسوريين بعد جاوب خليني
اجاوب ما بدي اجاوب طيب اولا قصه الكيماوي
يعني حفظ مش هو ضرب اخي انا ضربتها قصه
الكيماوي حفظناها كل ما سيطر الجيش في
مكان لا امن لا امانه النظام لحظه اولا من
يريد يلي عم يحكي من يريد ان يرفع السلاح
على الدوله سيخسر لان في المحصله الدوله
دوله لن تسمح لاحد ان يرفع السلاح لا في
سوريا ولا بفنزويلا ولا لو ذبحت
لعنته الا الله
خليني خلين
يكفي يا اخي خليني يكفي المصالحه الوطنيه
التي لا يرضيه ترضي كثيرين من الناس
والذين يستفيدون بكان بعد كل اللي سواه
بشار يا اخي مين قاللك ب ايده ومين قاللك
بالروح بدهم لا تنتخبوا ولا تخب اللي بدك
اه ورشح بدك خليني
نكفي او
اوكما خليني اقوللك شغله خليني اقوللك هذه
المصالحه اذا عممت في كل سوريا سوف تنهي
سفك الدم في سوريا سوف تعري الارهابيين
جميل
جيب عمر البغدادي مع ابو محمد مع ابو محمد
الجولاني الهندي مع فلان الافغاني مع فلان
الشيشاني وبتقلي ما في
مسلحين بما ان الارهابيين هم مخرب سوريا
ليش عم تصالح بشار الاسد مع
السور في
هناك دقيقه دقيقه يا اخي يا اخي اللي
يقاتل في سوريا ابو محمد الجولاني وابو
فنطس الازعر ابو زعيط المحنش ماشي مش
مختلف معك ماشي اذا ليش عم يعمل
مصالحات ما خليتني كفي هناك ناس من
السوريين انا لا اقول كلهم من الخارج هناك
ناس من السوريين هذه المناطق في ناس بدها
ترجع للدوله قالت لك انا رفعت السلاح ضد
الدوله وغلطت بدي ارجع وقتلت الجيش وقتلت
المواطنين لا لا لا لا هناك لا لا هناك من
يريد تعترف
بانه ص لظه لحظه هناك من يريد ان يعود الى
حضن الوطن مسموح له اخطا شو في كثير من
المواطنين حملوا السلاح لثلاثه اسباب اولا
لغزه ثانيا لمال ثالثا لتحريض اعلامي يعني
ما اشتغل التحريض
الاعلامي
صحو بعمل ح اذا بتريد خليني احكيم الحال
ه كل كلمه خذ الكلام الاعلامي المصري
مصطفى بكري في برنامج حقائق واسرار على
قناه صد البلد يعرض وثيقه تتضمن شكرا
ارسله رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
الى قناه الجزيره يقول في
اوجه يعني كانك يا
رجل ما اشتغلت ما اشتغلت على
التحريض خطه بندر من اول الثوره شو حاجه
ب شو رايك بالمص هذا يا اخي لك خطه
بندرب لا خلص خط مصدر مصدر خليني احكي اذا
بت يامع لا يحق لاحد ان يرفع السلاح بوجه
الدوله مين الدوله شبيحه حزب الله عراقيه
ايرانيه قال لي لا بقول لك بدل ناكم فيهم
اول امبارح مشان يطلعوا شباب من حمص من
وين اجا الايراني والعراقي اعطيني اسم
اثنين لا بعطيك صور
م ايرانيه كانت عم تستجم كانت عم تستجم
خص اسمع خلصني خليني احكي اذا بتريد عرفت
دوله هي بالنسبه لهق حضن الوطن هو حذاء
بشار الاسد ما اطعتك اط يعني السوريين يجب
ان يعودوا الى حض ان يركعوا تحت حزاء بشار
الاسد وان تنسى كل ام وكل اب جسس شهدائهم
في المقابر وان تدوس عليها بحذاء بشار
الاسد هذا حضن الوطن هي سوا هي سوا تبعكم
وهي سوا شو حمته شو رح اعطيك شعار شوف يا
اخي يا بتقولوا حملات مثل العالم سوا
ومادري شو نقتلكم سوا يا برمي لك كل مواطن
يا كيماوي للجميع يا مثلا لا تخشى مستقبل
طفلك نحن نتكفل بقتله بدك تلاقي لك هيك
شعار اما تقوللي سوا لك شو هو سياسي
السياسه قتل الناس وعملهم حملات مخره على
الانترنت جيبنا
الشبل اليوم انت بدك تحكي بعمل سياسي نحن
عم نحكي على موضوع لك شو عملك السياسي
السياسه بالنسبه لك هي البراميل تبع بشار
الاسد هي الجوع و
يعفو عن من الان نظام بشار الاسد وبعد كل
اللي سوته بالسوريين قال بدها تعفي عنهم
مين اللي بده يعفي عن الثاني بده
ينعفس ايده لابن هذا ايده ويعفوا معه
ويصالحه قال قال هو اللي قال قال نحن نسعى
جميعا للمصالحه واينما وجدتم مكان
للمصالحه علينا ان نتصالح لا تنقلوا كلام
شوف دكتور انت قد يكون بس اسمعني ش انت قد
يكون لديك مشكله او هم او كذا لكن يجب ان
نتحدث هذا النظام اذا لم يستطع ان يتحمل
اعلامي فبرك
لهي هذا
النظم انت الدوله وانت المحقق انت
المحقق مع شباب الجيش الحر
شريف عم ق انا عم احقق مع شباب الجيش
الحر اعتقل احد الشباب
و الهدن الهدنه طيب انا بدي اسالك انا
مواطن سوري ماشي انا اعلامي ماشي طيب اذا
هذا النظام لا يستطيع ان يتحمل اناسا
يحاوره بالكلام حتى لو سبوا عليه
دقيقه كيف تريد منه ان يعمل هدى مع الذين
اطلقوا عليه الرصاص والدبابات والمدافع
طيب ليش لكان ملاحق اعلاميين بدور على
واحد قريبه من بعد 500 سنه بروح بسكر له
محله بيص على املاكه بحط بحط الجيش الوثني
هذا
الصرامي على البيوتى ما هنا لا لا هذا
سؤال انا مواطن سوري مواطن سورال بدي اسال
هذا هذا بعد فيك تصالح
هذا يا اخي لا خليني اسال بدي اسالك تصالح
حسن ل فيك تصالح عل هو مصالح هو مصالح
هونو لا سؤال مصالحك مال السؤ سؤال
الدكتور مصالحتك شو اساسها بقاء بشار
الاسد وابنه هذه العائله الى الابد ونروح
نو بتجاوبني بتقولي اي شي هلا بتقول لي
ونحن والقائد لك انت بتعرف شو قلت له موسى
العمر من يومين قال لك ليش بدك تنتخب بشار
الاسد قلت له لانه قام وطنيه هذا هذا شلون
مين سالك موسى العمر على الغ هذا القناه
الغد مدري شو
اسمها عم تجيب كلام من عند اذا مش قامه
وطنيه
بش خلي لا تلعبوا بالالفا تلعب بالفا تلع
بالالفاظ انتم اثنين انتم اثنين ما
ح
الرئيس الاس
ر شريف هذا كله محسوب
عليكك هلا انتم جايين تعملوا حلقه ولا
جايين تطلعوا شغله المصالحه ببقاء بار
الاسد يا دكتور بس يجاوبني المصالحه باقي
باقي باقي الله الباقي لا تكبر الله
الباقي لا تكبر لا تكبر خليه خليه يب خليه
يب يب
يب سوريا ط بدي اسالك انا بدي اروح على
سوريا اهلا وسهلا اهلا
وسهلا
اخذ بعطيني بيتر بيتي رجعلي السرقات لك
دخلوا على البيوت لم يتركوا ابره في
البيوت هؤلاء
اللصوص
بح
كمان عرضت على
السورين جايب لك اخر اخر مصالحه كيف تمت
كيف تمت يا دكتور فيصل حاجيب لي صور انا
جايب لك صورمع لق لك وينه ابو جرات الغاز
جيشك جيشك بتعرف شو عم يسموهم الشبيحه شو
عم يسموها لجيشك عم يسمو عم يسموهم العفيش
لانه فوتوا على البيوت بيسالوا اللي بحمص
اللي بحمص شباب الجيش الحر ههم اللي سرقوا
طلعهم بشنطه ايدهم وبوته وكل شب طلعوا
بسلاحه مرفوعين الراس مع شنطه يد
طيبين جبتي الشبيحه المواطنين
قال
ه